so when you see this graphic uh
we can't argue that we are in a democracy since democracy
it is the power of the people therefore in all its components
But there the representatives of the people are
uh mostly members uh of the or sub-bourgeoisie
well,
not even the majority of us are talking in an overwhelming way
um so uh well
it has very concrete effects that I could see at the national assembly
uh it's that in fact at the national assembly you have bourgeois
here it is them and it is the bourgeois who themselves
on all the laws that will concern all the others,
that's what's crazy
hum and who will spare their own interests
uh,
little parenthesis
among the seventy-five percent there are many physicians
it is one of the most represented professions in the national assembly
and I can tell you that nothing is moving as far as legislation is concerned
related uh the fight against medical waste
it is part of the things where there is inertia
not possible in France
to say that liberal medicine
uh believes that she has the right to settle wherever she wants
especially no constraints
they call it coercion
I can say that when you talk about this the national assembly
they all scream what
there is no question of regulating the health sector
and to try to discipline the medical corporation that uses
uh frankly uh thanks to the social security but who refuses behind
uh to go to all the territories uh that don't have a doctor
and this is a real public health problem
I take this example
because
that it is really one sees well that there
is not a management of general interest
and then it is the case for all the laws related to the economy
it is the employer camp that is represented but then there
no problem
so we can't say that it is a democracy
but even if in our constitution
it is made clear that the MP is the representative of the people
It represents the nation
so we don't have the right and that's when I said it's a taboo
it's that in fact in the text we don't have the right to question that
if we bring these sociological data we will say yes but no
because by the operation of the holy spirit any bourgeois
who is a Member of Parliament
has the interests of the entire population in mind
this is really mythology
and which is shared by everyone and in fact the sociology
the assembly bah clashes with this mythology
we can see that there is a problem no uh
it can't work like that
so we are not uh we are not in fact in democracy
we call it what we want but it's not the case
uh,
at least if you are a little demanding about what democracy is
and what we see in terms of evolution is that
in fact the peak uh of which one
that I also have in mind,
eh,
it's the one from 1946
because it is a strong push of the communist party and the communist party
was one of the only political organizations in France that had
a workers' conception of politics
that is, to say
they are the workers
are to the workers to be represented by workers
so they are the ones we have to bring up in the party
but since this policy
it was abandoned
especially by the communist party which now really a bourgeois party
or petty
in any case
it's not people who have in mind his representation of the workers
but then what would it take to be more in a democracy?
then it would take a lot of things but already
no but already we could I'll take two or three go ahead
we could imagine no
but we could imagine uh in the proposals uh uh
yeah it's very partial
but and we want parity between men and women
it is essential
so why don't we also want social parity
we represent the categories socio-professionnels
in the same way as they are in society
frankly and if we had this we must imagine the effects what
that is,
we would have uh
20% of workers
that as soon as there are uh reforms of the labor code
blah blah blah completely off the ground
we talk about collaborators
you will have workers who are there among the deputies who say wait
look what I've experienced
so I think it would have some effect but of course
we can't conceive uh
things from a purely institutional point of view
we may have the most socially equal institutions possible
as long as motherhood has this level of power over our lives via work
via the media
via cultural productions
we may have a socially balanced national assembly
well,
that will bother him for sure
but it won't solve the problem
so in fact we must act on all fronts at once
including effectively the institutional front
but I am just wary of solutions that speak only of the institutional front
for example the question of harassment
it is very important because indeed diabetes
if it were,
if it were used more often,
it would short-circuit
uh this social self and it was the case in 2005
on the European constitutional treaty uh well
for the blow the generator has short-circuited
uh the kind of bourgeois symbiosis that reigned around the yes
and the name came up because in fact we consulted people differently
so of course if we had rings more often uh
it's sure that things would be better
but the bourgeois have to revive democracy afterwards
yes well yes exactly small problem
that's the problem
the rest of the story is that even despite this expression
and still there was this frantic race
towards theinstitutionnalisation of this European Union
so it also failed
so that's why I say in fact uh yes the bourgeois
they are in such a position of strength that
could impose institutional croquettes on them
and that they will always manage to get around them
so we must act on both fronts
the exceptional issue must be resolved while strengthening the power
of the dark